now go to wisdom chapter 18: 13- 16
wisdom 18: 13-
16 chapter vers 18 wisdom 13 16 right
your all powerful word leaped from
heaven from the Royal Throne into the
midst of a wisdom chapter 18 verse 13-
16 13 excuse me yeah 13 for they
disbelieved everything because of their
sorceries but at the destruction of
their firstborn they acknowledged the
people to be God's son now what is it
referring to here what event no what is
it referring to what event not wisdom uh
the chapter here says death visits Egypt
but I don't know if it's yeah we forget
about subheading you just read it when
did they acknowledge Israel was God's
son when their firstborn was killed they
they realized Israel was your son when
their firstborn was
killed yeah who is this what event this
is referring
to this events refers to back to Egypt
right yeah so what do we call it sir so
what this this event what do we call
this event Timmy when the firstborn were
slain and the sorcerers failed in
matching the miraculous power of God and
then they realized The Exodus say it
again The Exodus you got it man okay
same man no I don't want to give it away
sometimes ask questions because when I
force you to think then it sinks in
right if you always give an answer oh
but when I say what it means then it
forces you to think and as you're
thinking it's going to be second nature
right right exactly that's by the grace
of the Spirit by the grace of the spirit
that that's why people why do you ask
questions because in asking questions
I'm G to force you to start thinking and
meditate and focus hard instead of you
just listening and me spoon feeding you
get it now
you're teaching lovingly yeah that's I
want you to learn it so now you're going
to share it now you know so this thought
about the Exodus right exactly because
The Magicians tried to match the
Miracles of Moses right yeah that's the
sorcerers here right right that's The
Magicians when they confronted Moses
when he threw the rod they threw a rod
and became a snake right but then Moses
is a snake So it's talking about The
Magicians at the time of Moses when they
tried to match Moses is Miracle but then
eventually they realize no this is the
Finger of God uh we can't our sorcery
can't match him then when God killed
their firstborn then Pharaoh let God's
son go right yeah so this is The Exodus
now here's what I want you to pay
attention whom did God send to kill the
Egyptians and their firstborn to set
Israel free that's the question I want
you to see in the text now go ahead okay
verse 14 for while gentle silence
embrace everything and night at its own
speed was half over your all powerful
word leaped from heaven from the Royal
Throne whoa whoa whoa there
Nelly it says that God's Almighty word
you're all powerful word came out of
your
throne came down from your throne to the
Earth so who's there with God on the
throne his word Loos in wisdom wisdom
chapter chapter n it was his
wisdom in wisdom 9:10 who came down from
the Glorious Throne wisdom
right chapter 9 verse 10 correct correct
yeah but here in wisdom 18 it's the word
so you see how the word is the wisdom
the wisdom is the word yeah yeah so the
word is the wisdom and the wisdom is the
word they're the same entity they're
both on the throne and they come down
either to save regenerate transform
illuminate or to punish and kill now
God's Almighty word comes down weere
that part again and I won't stop you
till 16 sure your all powerful word
leaps from heaven from the Royal Throne
into the midst of a doomed land a
Relentless Warrior carrying the sharp
sword of your irrevocable command and he
stood and filled all things with death
and touched Heaven while standing on
Earth did you catch it word the word
appeared as a visible
being he appeared in visible bodily
shape he was such a huge figure that
when his feet touched the Earth he was
so tall that he reached the
heaven that means the word is appearing
invisible form as a huge gigantic human
a huge gigantic human figure so he
assumed visible human shape so you Jed's
feet touched the Earth as his upper body
reached
Heaven you see that yeah and what did he
kill them with what did the word kill
them with a Relentless Warrior carrying
the sharp sword okay so let's make the
connection the all powerful Almighty
word of God because in verse 15 says the
word is Almighty right
right he came down invisible form
invisible shape appearing in human shape
that was so humongous that his feet
touched the Earth while his upper body
reached heaven and he slew he killed the
firstborn of the Egyptians by the sword
that he carries right yeah so God's all
powerful word sits on the throne God's
all powerful word is sent to save his
people and punish evildoers and God's
all powerful word can appear inv visible
human shape and he has a sword by which
to slay God's enemies right yeah now
let's see what who Jesus is go to
Revelation
3:21 Revelation 3:21
3:21 to the one who is Victorious I will
give the right to sit with me on my
Throne just as I was Victorious and sat
down with my father on his throne okay
wait Jesus sits on the father's Throne
right yeah with the father and the word
sits with who with the father and wisdom
sits with with who the wisdom sits with
with the father with God so wisdom and
the word must be one and the same
because wisdom and the word are both
seated with God on his throne so there
it shows that wisdom is the word word is
the wisdom right yeah and Jesus sits on
the throne with his father now go to
Revelation 19 11-6 see who Jesus is and
how he comes to destroy and kill the
enemies of God Revelation 191 to6 so you
here you got the the trinity in the D
chonicles and the wisdom Solomon and
then I'm going to show you the book of
sirak uh Revelation 19 11-16 yes sir I I
saw heaven standing open and there
before me was a white horse whose Rider
is called faithful and true with Justice
he W he judges and wages War his eyes
are like blazing fire and on his heads
are many crowns he has a name written on
on him that no one knows but he himself
he is dressed in a rogue drip in Blood
and his name is the word of God wait so
what's his name the word of God and the
word of God is coming on a white horse
with the armies of Heaven to slay the
false prophet the Beast and their armies
and how's he going to slay them keep
reading the armies of Heaven were
following him riding on white horses and
dressed in fine linen with white and
clean coming out of his mouth is a sharp
sword with which to stri down to Nations
you confuse me Jesus is the word of God
who slays people with a sword that comes
out of his
mouth you got it right yeah I got it but
in wisdom 18 13- 16 the wisdom Salomon
18: 13- 16 there it says God's all
powerful word comes down to slay people
with the sword that he has wow oh that's
might Revelation tells us Jesus is that
word of God who comes down from the
throne and he has a sword by which he
slays people now I'll explain what it
means sword out of his mouth but keep
reading because you read 15 Read to 16
keep
read um he will rule them with an iron
scepter he treats The Wine Press of the
fury of the wrath of God Almighty on his
rope and on his thigh he has written
this name king of kings and Lord of
lords Now read verse 21 of the same
chapter Revelation 1921
yeah the rest were killed with the sword
coming out of his mouth of the rider on
the horse and all the birds gorged
themselves on their flesh so Jesus is
the word of God whom God sends to slay
God's enemies and save his people and
Jesus does that by this sword out of his
mouth now obviously Jesus is appearing
with a sword in his mouth but he
literally doesn't walk around with a
physical sword in his mouth so why Jesus
appearing in this image of a rider on a
horse with a sword in his mouth because
this is a metaphorical way of showing
you that Jesus's words cut you dead when
Jesus speaks his words are like a sword
that will kill you dead or his words
will speak life if you're his Enemy by
his word he'll slay you and kill you
dead right you caught
it so are you seeing how wisdom chapter
7 guys just remember these chapters
wisdom chapter 7 you can read from 22 on
wisdom chapter 9
the entire chapter of 18 verses and
wisdom chapter 18 veres 13- 16 there you
see the Trinity you see God his wisdom
who is also his word they're one and the
same that sits on the throne with God
and the word of God and the wisdom of
God are set to be all powerful all
penetrating All Pure wisdom is set to be
monogen wisdom 7:22 that wisdom is the
only begotten and wisdom said to be the
radiance of God's Eternal Light aasma
the same word used of Jesus in Hebrews
13 and wisdom is the one that comes and
illuminates saves sanctifies and
transforms sons of men and wisdom works
with the Holy Spirit to do so because in
wisdom 9:17 wisdom comes down from God's
throne with the Holy Spirit to
illuminate Enlighten and save Mankind
and the word of God is the one who slays
people by his sword so wisdom and word
are the same they work with the Holy
Spirit and together word who is wisdom
and the Holy Spirit are sent by God to
save regenerate transform illuminate or
punish and kill that's in the dter
Chronicles